hi this is Tom Rhodes
please join me as I scour the four
corners of the earth to bring you
interesting and intelligent funny people
who will enrich your life with wisdom
and laughter I'll take you to Europe
Australia all over America I might take
you to the peaks of Machu Picchu the
canals of Amsterdam the Great Wall of
China or the swamps of Florida and
certainly the many many comedy clubs and
comedy theaters all over the world come
hang out with me and meet the many
interesting people that pop up in my
life as I travel the world as a stand-up
comedian so traveling across America on
my big summer adventure after I did
Montreal I flew back to Texas and then I
had a week in El Paso and then I stopped
off in Arizona and saw my old friend
Doug Stanhope and Doug Stanhope you know
he's he's a worldwide badass comedian
who plays everywhere and he's really a
genius at what he's done with creating
his own following and going into rock
clubs and things but he's also a great
guy I've known him forever and it's he's
got a really cool house in Arizona and
it was really late and we had been
drinking and I basically forced the
microphone on him and had a big chat
with him reminder Doug Stanhope did this
interviews on ambien and several
cocktails you will never remember the
things he says but he'll probably back
them up a hundred percent in lighter
tones
one of my favorite human beings on the
planet Earth Doug Stanhope I've come to
your house in Bisbee Arizona your
gangster outlaw hideout right on the
Mexican border safe house the way that
any outlaw should be living but I want
to first start out with how I met you is
really such a fantastic story because we
were both skinny
we both had long hair when we were both
mildly attractive young fellows and it
was the NBC Friday late-night something
I don't even remember the show exactly
but it was late night on Friday on NBC
they had videos music videos this is
like the early 90s and then they would
do and they filmed it in Burbank in a
nice studio stand-up and they had
stand-up Clips interspersed with rock
videos and that's how cool comedy was
back at the time and then the most
amazing thing was this was one of my
first television appearances ever and I
meet Doug Stanhope and they asked this
it was before we had done the stand-up
segment they did these silly interviews
and they ask you all these questions
where are you from what kind of job have
you done before comedy and who's your
biggest comedy influences and I had said
I'm from Oviedo Florida a charming
little citrus village and the only job I
ever had before I was a stand-up
comedian was I bagged groceries at meat
world in Oviedo Florida made our own
world there's what is the finest meat
you'll ever eat and
and for my comedy influence I said my
all-time comedy hero was Yosemite Sam oh
and that's what I remember of it but the
from the interview but the most
memorable things and the whole
experience was you know this is my first
experience you know working in
television and one of my first TV gigs
I'm hanging out oh my god I want to see
the guy that's going on after me you
know I you know we nodded to each other
or whatever silverback gorillas do to
each other first smell each other's
scent I'm watching you get interviewed
and you it was hysterical you gave all
of my answers every question you said
well I'm a boy I said I'm from a
charming little citrus village in
Florida called Oviedo and I bagged
groceries at meat world and that your
your comedy hero is Yosemite Sam and I
remember that the production people got
so angry with you they stopped and
started this interview well three or
four times you're like okay this is your
last chance quit [__] around I
remember them getting really harsh with
you and you were just pissing in your
pants with laughter and you gave the
same responses every time I'm from
Oviedo Florida meat world Yosemite Sam
and I'm watching you and I thought it
was absolutely the funniest thing I've
ever seen in the book but what I thought
was why would this guy be [__] up his
first television chance because I
remember it was sacred to me I was like
the thing that I remember the most about
it was like if to me it was so
mind-blowing that you would [__] around
with your first opportunity on
television what do you remember from
that well that hey this is Doug Stanhope
on ambien so I will recall none of this
but the media will ask you the same
boring [__] questions that nobody
wants to hear where did you get started
who gives a [__] about your jokes that
one always kills me Lenny come up with
your material come from I'll get it from
a vending machine at the bus station it
doesn't
well how is this interesting to people
where do you get your ideas what they do
want to be a comedian I don't know I was
[__] funny perhaps I had a
predilection to the [__] concept of
it oh no I wanted to be a comedian
because because I saw other people
getting the adulation for it and
couldn't play guitar I have four fingers
if they're so [__] dumb so ya know
what you've been one of my oldest
friends in the business forever
and let's just drunk jump straight to
you know and it's it's it's why I'm the
most proudest of you I mean it's because
you mean you know some comedians when
they do well using all that [__]
but when it's a guy that your buddy and
your friend and you've known forever you
like wow you know I'm really it's always
so nice in a business full of bitterness
and hatred when you genuinely feel good
for somebody and you had a long road I
want you to tell me about I know there
was a lot of clubs that you had been
banned from for doing [__] I remember it
with San Antonio you did the thing where
you tried to stop her own desk ladies do
you think you know your man pretty well
did you have an honest relationship with
your fellow I don't care if you've been
with your man for five minutes or 50
years this is the one thing you don't
know what to man ladies regardless of
him telling you otherwise after this
show
the one thing you don't know about your
man ladies at one point in every man's
life in this room he has tried to suck
his own dick
oh yes oh yes at one point in every
man's life in this room he has gotten up
onto his back shoulder raise his legs
over and let it dangle to see he was
that one lucky member of cirque de
soleil who could suck his own dick i
actually tried that when i was 14 years
old nights stuck like that so
embarrassing my dad walked in on you
said it doesn't work does it you guys
are great and we're back
no it's nice that the microphone cut out
right then because it gave me a minute
to try to formulate my answer and I
don't know that I'm an outlaw guy is I'm
just doing a different path that's more
comfortable for me it's so hard for me
to formulate words right now but come on
what about what drove you to [__] off so
many clubs where you just had you know
and for me I always really thought it
was dangerous that you these chances
that you were taken where you would piss
off the club's what do you remember out
there what do you remember of pissing
off clubs why did you do it and how
pissed off did people get do you
remember I just said I took a [__]
ambien my brain is for [__]
that's what ambien does for you but what
do I remember I remember [__] comedy
clubs they're the same today as they
were ever
well yeah you say something someone
doesn't like and they get upset and say
and today if I went in to a comedy club
today and I [__] did fist-fucking a
rape baby [__] the most should be
offensive bit and then I said you know
and their diabetes as an aside some girl
would run out crying about diabetes
you said diabetes we know I was talking
about fist-fucking a dead abortion
and you got upset because I said it had
diabetes because your father just died
of diabetes
there's no the transition into rock
club's was because I could draw my own
audience I I've done enough [__]
years where people know who I am and
with MySpace and Facebook people can
find you and you have direct contact
with those people you don't have to go
through a comedy club you don't have to
worry about one guy in Richmond deciding
whether you're funny because he counts
[__] comment cards and that's what he
does for a living oh the chicken wings
were lousy number two comment card
didn't like the headliner number three
comment card you should have smoothies
alright and that's how he judges comedy
yeah
and now when you have the [__]
Internet audience deciding whether or
not you're funny and they can sign up to
be your [__] pallor buddy or your
Twitter space finger [__] buddy well now
you know well you've been incredibly
genius with that and and I have to bow
down to you Doug is my friend you know I
mean as a comedian you've helped me you
were the video the microphone no I was
like the last guy in the world
[__] Dane Cook was the guy that was
derided for being some oh he's getting
all those [__] buddies from MySpace
and as as though that's bad but no
people like that America likes shitty
[__] entertainment and that's
something that you just have to like
succumb to and acquiesce yes America
likes shitty [__] entertainment it's
not being cooks bad America is bad what
you treat what you say is true sir but
what the point that I'm making is that
you've really been a pioneer in forging
your own audience and breaking off of
the comedy clubs because I mean for most
people that's the only route and you as
my friend I have to thank you forever I
mean you know even child molesters don't
use MySpace now but
at one time myspace was really hot and a
few years ago you sat me down and said
no you have to you're doing this right
now and and it was true I mean instantly
I had you know 300 friends and then it
kept growing from there and I had no
idea I was just such a Luddite
Comparative a Luddite and you what
you've done with the internet and
playing worldwide I think is you're like
the hey you're the sweaty little white
version of Jackie Robinson and I applaud
you on MySpace I know it sounds gay as
[__] but it's great marketing it's great
[__] works beautifully but the with
the press that myspace gets you can't
even log into your myspace account
without thinking I must just be here to
[__] his cuz every news story you hear
myspace it's a new playground for
pedophiles if you have a child on
MySpace be very careful cuz there's
nothing but people want to [__] your
kids I was just trying to get people to
the show they act like myspace is
creating pedophiles out of thin air
people become pedophiles how does this
myspace work I login I fill out a
profile and some of my favorite pillows
and a few photographs of myself and now
I can meet people with similar interests
in my own area why haven't I been
[__] children all these years this
seems like this is such an easy
this has many pedophiles in the world as
there ever have been if I were a parent
I would prefer that pedophiles were on
myspace keep them on the Internet
people jacking off in their own basement
in South Carolina as opposed to the
old-fashioned way where they did laps
around a schoolyard try to fly-fish
junior into the Oldsmobile and Smarties
on a fishing line just don't [__] the
kid that should be enough right don't
[__] the kid though yeah beat off look
at a picture think about it just don't
[__] the kid I mean they they exist
anyway I know if you're a parent and
you're out there you probably don't want
to hear this but the truth is and
probably statistical Vegas odds high
probability probably nobody wants to
[__] your kid now or ever I know you
don't want to hear it you want to think
that kid is the reason for all the
problems all the pedophiles are out
there jockeying for position in the
schoolyard way from that little
towheaded beauty oh yes no not the
chubby kid the O'Neal kid from my space
my spaceman my space my let's go get
them if you wanted your kid to get
[__] just to prove the point about how
ultra [__] that kid is you probably
couldn't make it happen if you sent them
out as bait and you put him in a little
Catholic schoolgirl skirt you made him
hop on a pogo stick with no underpants
so his little pink fleshy hindquarters
Sodor's the traffic's so tempting it
still probably graduate school having
ever been boomed and then what an
[__] you'd look like one thing about
your being your friend for many years
and it's it's something that happens to
me occasionally I don't know with your
new rock and roll club life how much it
happens anymore but I remember seeing
you many times over the years
where in comedy clubs and I love how you
talked about and you're right about
people in comedy clubs get upset easily
where people would get up and walk out
of your show and it's happened to me
several times periodically through the
years and I'm telling you it twists my
guts to see someone get up and leave a
[__] show I'm a shameless [__] and I
want to entertain you always seem to
have kind of taken delight in when
people get upset and leave your shows
that's the difference between back then
comedy clubs entertain an audience that
the same way a chuck-e-cheese entertains
children okay if you come to a comedy
club you will have this type of fare
that's how comedy clubs they it's all
Bob Saget on funny videos that type of
humor it's not gonna hurt your feelings
and so when people would leave a comedy
club yeah I would take pleasure in the
fact that you put no forethought into
the type of entertainment you have
[__] Friday and Saturday you live for
that you bust your balls all week and
you're gonna pick some form of
entertainment because Friday and
Saturday is that's what it's for
I pick something out of the weekly guide
I put my finger on it randomly either
it's an Adam Sandler movie or its comedy
or it's [__] karaoke contest and you
show up without any kind of insight to
what you're seeing so people like that
[__] dumb I would take pleasure in
them walking up
but now that I'm doing my own thing
doing rock-and-roll clubs yeah I get
yeah it hurts my guts when someone who
likes me for the wrong reasons or a
different reason I can do fist-fuck
jokes I can do abortion material I can
do socially relevant or really dark dick
jokes and people will like me for
different reasons oh dude transvestite
hooker talk about 9/11 okay I do both
and it will always piss off someone and
when you have someone that's your own
fan that leaves
ya [__] you gotta [__] do better
one way or another yeah that hurts it
always hurts but it hurts a lot more
when they were fans of yours and they
walk out then they were just a
bachelorette party that walks out
because you said [__] well we've been
friends for a long time and you making
people walk out it's a feeling I'll
never ever be able to get used to I
don't care and you see people get up and
they're leaving it obvious they don't
you know whatever you don't think you're
funny or they were offended by something
and you that was the thing I wanted to
ask you I've really mastered that I mean
you really know I don't know what it
probably doesn't happen too much now but
like I remember seeing you in comedy
clubs and you would always upset people
and and that's why a lot of clubs had
problems with you and you were just so
fearless and you didn't give a [__] and
you gave it to them what you want you're
just you know you reach the level of
honesty and doing what you wanted to do
where you know it frightens some people
in middle America so my question is you
know did you in the beginning
did it ever twist your guts when people
left and and do you kind of get off on
it when when when you when you see like
an older white you know crusty couple
being ruffled by your thoughts
no actually more often than not the
people that enjoy me are old white
crusty couples but first of all you and
I do different different acts because we
have different sensibilities I always
feel off put where I go like tonight I
said something where you I probably
sound like the biggest douchebag in the
world because you're a very positive
person and I'm a very negative person
yeah so so but I'm saying because of
that the way you feel about a walkout
would be different someone walking out
on you would be a different walkout than
I would have someone would have
disagreement with a point of view that I
had oh everything you said abortion was
funny fist buck was funny and until you
mentioned cancer and none of my dad died
of cancer that's when you went over the
edge fist-fucking your baby's funny but
my dad died of cancer and you had a
cancer drug so yeah but you're upbeat
and positive so yeah your walkouts are
different and I would feel the same if I
had your act and I had a walk out where
I'm going hey I'm just trying to
entertain and I hang on uh also I forget
my point here take the microphone take
it from me I think also that I'm more
sensitive and that's I think basically
what I'm trying to ask you is that you
know like sometimes you'll talk to
people no you know like they're outside
you know oh I saw you leave early and
they're like oh my kid had a sitter and
I had to make a call and it had nothing
to do with you but you're my insecure
neurotic comedy brain is oh my god
they've enough said buy something
sometimes they are and then sometimes
you find out who knows what the [__]
maybe somebody's got to call his dying
mother in the [__] hospital and the
guy's trying to laugh and forget about
some [__] so now I'm from Orlando
Florida which by every man
juror is a candy ass [__] kind of a
place sunshine and Happiness and you're
from Worcester Mass outside of Boston
and so I mean so this is where I'm my
long question is getting at is you know
do you think just that that area kind of
hardens you like I know people from
Philly are really they got a really
black sense of humor and and they don't
give a [__] about hurting people's
feelings I left there so early that I
never realized that it was even a dumb
place to live when I left Worcester I
thought oh yeah we're all smart people
that's the you know this [__] they sell
you well the Northeast were the smartest
people and South is dumb and [__]
West Coast is daft yeah so ya know I I
really anywhere you go the [__]
people are equally different I mean you
might have an overriding theme if you're
in Utah and you're you have that Mormon
over set yeah there might be but people
are [__] equally individual wherever
you are the [__] chunk of dirt you're
born in has [__] so little to do with
who you are as a human being I mean it
might affect your accent it might affect
your you know even your sense of humor
you know yes definitely the East Coast
has a more wicked sense of humor where
you [__] you you [__] [__] you know
that doesn't mean anything but overall
is you're still the individual you are
you just have a different accent and
there's some overriding themes where you
I [__] hate you know crowded places
because of where I grew up but what it's
it's all dog [__] we have no [__]
idea its self-help books are a perfect
example of oh you know you're like this
because this and I read the self-help
okay now the reason that I
lots of [__] ice cream I figured out
is because my [__] parents didn't
never take me I was sledding what my
brothers or some dumb [__] and you go
okay now you know or you think you know
why you are the way you are how does it
change you not at all
I still leave lots of [__] ice cream
but now I know no you don't know you
don't know [__] you are the way you are
for whatever [__] reason you're funny
because not cuz you're from a point of
bugging you know a compass point on a
map you're funny cuz you're funny it's
nothing to do with what area you grew up
in and all this dumb [__] comics talk
about comics a [__] stupid [__] cuz
it appeals to stupid [__] people
Einstein said great spirits will always
encounter violent opposition from
mediocre minds but what he didn't
reinforce is the fact that mediocrity
will always be the masses they're always
gonna be king so you can be you're
always encounter that yeah it's not
something you overcome will always have
[__] mediocre people and will never
know what the [__] going on until
we're dead at best we might not even
know then death might be like have you
figured it out yet no you're going back
it's all [__] nothing makes sense
everything's [__] and making people
laugh is like throwing biscuits at dogs
maybe they catch one in their mouth
happiness list number 1127 petting your
friends like animals
why can't you pet your friends like you
do animals I have many friends and
sometimes this is a very long time until
I see them and when I do I just want to
pet them like a - now let me ask you
this let's jump to a period in our lives
when I have so many romantic visions of
these days when there was a period when
me you and Mitch Hedberg were we were
the three musketeers of excess is the
way I've described it to close friends
and if we were not together we were
plotting to be together what do you
think I'll tell you my favorite story of
Tom Rhodes Mitch Hedberg and Doug
Stanhope hanging and that was and then I
want to hear one you might have the
Chicago Comedy Festival and your brother
was there and it's a famous photograph
it's on friggin the internet it's on the
internet somewhere you can find it and
it's me Hugh and Mitch and your brother
naked and there's a female comedian
that's in the room and she's fully
clothed but it was a funny really funny
thing that had happened we were you know
we were the best of friends the three of
us we hung out a lot and got together
and did weird little you know we'd be on
the road we'd all some somehow meet
somewhere party our skulls out in hotel
rooms and then the Chicago Comedy
Festival they were trying to get off the
ground
and we were there and the three of us
were partying all night and some chick
that was unwanted had followed us I
don't know she worked at the club or
what her story was but this girl and she
emerges we're just so inebriated it was
unwanted nobody would have [__] her
but someone [__] her so she was wanted
but go ahead okay I didn't recall that
all I remembered was that the chick was
really annoying and the word that I
haven't you know we're like the three
musketeers we're having the time of our
lives
laughing it up like brothers and your
brother is there and like I had never
met your brother before your brother is
a [__] wonderful dude and so me you
Hedberg and your brother are just
liquored and laughing and everything is
hysterical I mean the kind of like
teenage laughter were your stomach hurts
and you know it's given you like muscles
on your stomach of you're laughing so
hard like that kind of just pure
wonderful laughter and there was a
female comedian with us who was cool I
can't remember who it was but she's
she's in the photograph I think she was
a friend of mine Lisa sunset yes that's
what it was and so the annoying chick
this is my version of the story goes
into the bathroom and it was your idea
it was so funny you go hey man let's all
rip off our clothes and we'll be naked
when she comes back out and let's just
be talking like it's no big deal and so
and and it was like it wasn't even
anything huge those words left your
mouth you me your brother Hedberg we
jump up and stripped completely naked
Lisa's son son said did not do it and
we're sitting there and it was totally
the the joke that you wanted to play on
this chick she comes out of the bathroom
and we're all sitting there talking
naked completely naked and she goes what
the [__] and then we took the photograph
and that's a lot of people have asked me
about that photograph they've seen it on
the inner
Hedberg [__] her in the bathroom and
that we're all depressed because it
wasn't us oh I didn't know Hedberg poked
her because like I said in the many
years that I hung out with Hedberg I he
was never really a [__] hound the guy
he loved drugs loved hanging out loved
being with comedians he was never an ego
hound he was never a [__] hound he
wasn't even a drug hound unless like he
wasn't the guy going alright let's go
find the guy with drugs he was if drugs
were there he'd do them no [__] doubt
but he was never a [__] hound he didn't
care about no Mitch was the mayor of fun
City you know and I think you have that
disease I have that disease Hedberg was
different Hedberg made his own fondant
fun city was he could be alone no I had
burger even in the open-mike days not
open-mike but [__] shitty one-nighter
days Hedberg would duck out the back
door because he was afraid to face the
people that he performed for and he was
[__] opening he was an opening act and
he walked out the back door just cuz he
was afraid to [__] talk to the people
I remember the first time I met Hedberg
was in Pacifica California I had moved
to San Francisco in 1990 somewhere in
that area of 1991-1992
I think Hedberg had started out in
Florida and then he moved to Pacifico
Pacifica it's between Santa Cruz and San
Francisco and I remember him coming out
and doing gigs and he was so cripplingly
shy and his jokes were funny but like he
never really got a good response it was
really interesting that I don't I think
comics all the comics loved him
everybody loved I loved him he you know
he would say you gotta watch this guy
the first time I ever met him in
Minneapolis was a [__] black comic
from Denver I forget his name and
there's a you gonna watch this guy Lewis
Johnson yes Lewis Johnson
great guy and our first acid trip was
that a week in Minneapolis and Lewis
Johnson became such a focal point of one
of the best acid trips I've ever had
with Hedberg in the Hampton Inn Lewis
Johnson and his [__] promo
you you you could never understand
unless you were there but just goofing
on you you can't you can't you can't
recreate a [__] acid trip oh you know
it's like trying to tell someone a dream
and make it make sense
and then Lewis Johnson and then we were
watching a KKK documentary on HBO where
they infiltrated and then we were making
Lewis Lewis Johnson jokes within it and
it's not gonna make sense but you do
acid one time with a guy you bond all
your percent and much like you and I on
mushrooms clutching onto the earth here
in Bisbee when we held onto the earth as
if we were going to fall off
pasen was my favorite drug acid opened
up my mind and expanded my mind because
i acid I now know that butter is way
better than margarine I saw through the
[__] when I was on acid I see things
like beams of light and out here sounds
have sounded an awful lot like car horns
when we were on acid we're going to the
woods because we're in the woods trip
and there's less like a chance he'd run
into an authority figure but we ran into
a bag that was even more of a buzzkill
my friend Dewayne was standing there
raising his right hand swearing to help
prevent forest fires
we got him away from the bear he put his
arm around my shoulder he said Mitchell
smokey is way more intense in person I
went to England to tell jokes and I
wanted to do my Smokey the Bear joke in
England so I had to ask the English
people if they know Smokey the Bear was
but they don't because in England Smokey
the Bear is not the forest fire
prevention representatives
they have smacky the Frog it's a lot
like a bear but it's a frog and I think
that's a better system I think we should
adopt it because bears can be mean but
frogs are always cool I've never had a
better Frog happen toward me and I
thought man I better play dad here comes
that frog I've never said here comes
that frog in a horrifying manner it's
always like optimistic like hey here
comes that frog alright maybe you will
set them near me and I can pet him and
put him in a mayonnaise jar with a stick
and a leaf to recreate what he's used to
and I certainly have to punch some holes
in the lid because he's damn sure used
to add and then I can observe him and he
won't be doing much in his 16-ounce
world so I want to bring it back to the
many years I've been your friend and
seeing you walking people and upsetting
people and I you know and it goes back
to the very first moment when I met you
or did the NBC late-night videos and you
go on this thing and you gave all my
answers you said hi I'm from Oviedo
Florida it's charming citrus village and
I you somebody Sam and you're pissing
off these producers and I remember
laughing hysterically and I'm watching
you been alone this guy is [__] gonna
be my friend forever I thought it was so
specifically hilarious only to me you
were doing it for me I mean I was your
audience who else is your audience when
you're a comic who else do you think
Dane Cook takes I don't want to but when
you get appreciation from your peers
that's the only thing that matters you
could have [__] Madison Square Garden
doesn't matter they're [__] idiots
the mediocrity are going to give you
violent opposition when do you make your
peers laughs that's what counted it's
all the counted to me is when your
[__] comic friends said you know what
that was [__] funny
whether it's individually or in a group
in the back of the room I mean like I
thought it was the funniest thing I've
ever seen in my life and then there's
been many things through the years I've
seen you do or I'm like oh my god that's
the funniest thing I've ever seen in my
life but you're shocking people and
you're upsetting a certain percentage of
the people
and God what was the point the point is
that that was the most funny thing in
the world to you because it was about
you and that's where you see how easy it
is to play on ego and you can say oh
I'll copy his answers and that guy will
think I'm the funniest guy in the world
because you were the funniest guy in the
show so I'll appeal to you and you
appeal to ego and that's you know you
see how easy the con of all of humanity
is and you know this is not really
[__] challenging okay no I just
remembered my point and then maybe you
won't see it all as some big con through
the years watching you do these things
and me thinking that's the funniest
[__] thing I've ever seen in my life
and then some you know [__] stuffy
old couple gets upset and leaves or some
TV producers get pissed whatever you
really forged your own Avenue in this
business which is a very difficult thing
to do and you did it in spite of the
business because a lot of clubs he
didn't want to work you because you were
so controversial
so that was my point that I had
remembered that like Lenny Bruce man
that guy took hard knocks and he's
remembered forever as an icon and yes
that's an overused word now but Lenny
Bruce was a [__] icon because no
comedian could say [__] or
whatever on stage today if it wasn't for
that groundbreaking guy so you've taken
things anything but full full-body
Underpants to go swimming so yeah a lot
of people broke a lot of boundaries I
don't give any credence here's my
question what are the hardest knocks
that you have taken in going that route
I've taken no hard knocks whatsoever
that was a that was call waiting know
this call waiting there's another
is another iPod guest coming in anyway
yeah I've taken no hard knocks
whatsoever there's nothing off [__]
limits anymore
we are doing comedy in an age Deena lies
but oh nothing's hurt me I'm [__]
done really well yeah the people you you
get fired from a club because you got a
bad comment card but this is not just
one club yeah I mean there's people that
we think are the most atrocious boring
dull acts in the world and they're still
getting [__] work they work clubs
laughs and Tucson again we go I don't
know anyone who works at but people are
someone's working that circuit so yeah
we can all get work I've never been hurt
by any of it any if I get fired for a
good reason
it inspired me it inspired me to go
harder and dig deeper into what you know
affects people's souls so much when
you're just trying to be funny all
you're trying to do is be funny and
people get angry about it it baffles me
it baffles me why people get and I'm I'm
I'm one of them I watch TV
I see Nancy Grace on [__] whatever
headline news for three minutes I'm I
want to kill her litter I would have no
problem killing her I would have no
problem in my soul extinguishing her
from and but I'm just trying to be funny
I understand why I want to kill her but
I never want to [__] about Larry the
Cable guy's ordained cooks or frank
caliendo's or Lisa lampanelli's where I
disagree with everything you're trying
to portray but I would hang out with you
in an airport bar and we would drink and
I
five the worst comic I could talk to
before the best audience member there's
a certain fraternity and being a
comedian and I think that's my favorite
thing about it is that it doesn't matter
if you're black or gay or poor or
whatever your background is all that
matters all that matters is if you're
funny and this is the it's a difficult
business to survive in no it doesn't
even matter if you're funny
you can be a shitty comic and we still
want to hang around with you because
you've done this you know what it's like
you know the audience is the enemy so it
doesn't matter if you're funny or not I
would still rather hang around with the
[__] worst comic in the world than
the best fan yeah that's a good point
and that's a good point and you know I
consider anyone who does it it's not the
best point if you want a fanbase to
admit publicly but yeah will you sign my
[__] daughters as she has muscular
dystrophy she's gonna die in in a year
so will you sign her cuz she's always
smiled every time we laughed at your
comedy you know okay but you know what
Dane Cook any he's my personal nemesis
and I for fun what he didn't feel he
didn't heal some chick with muscular
sclerosis you did the point is I if I
ran into Dane Cook at an airport I have
no animosity I just don't like his
comedy but and we because we're in
industry your [__] plumber and this
guy uses a [__] new joint where you
use an F joint and you go that's not
even good plumbing but if you're in an
airport bar you'd rather hang around
with a plumber than a [__] customer
that's just how [__] life works but
people [__] bite on animosity they
want to see a fight they want to see Joe
Rogan versus Mencia and pick a side the
same way they want to watch Dancing with
the Stars you wouldn't watch Dancing you
don't even [__] dance but
you'll watch people compete because you
won't compete cuz you get a day job and
you are good and Little League but now
it's all [__] over so you want to
watch people compete any time someone
has a fight you want to have a [__]
I'm gonna just sit by the sidelines and
pick a guy that's my guy well I hope he
wins this fight I'll argue for him
without leaving the couch you all
[__] suck you're [__] a dreadful
race of [__] people awful awful
species of animal that should [__] be
extinguished and I you know this parts
of Hitler that I go you know if you
didn't make it SEC yeah you know yeah
secular wait why is it a Jew thing why
isn't it just awful people need to die
Speight Nana ma city you put on the
opposite the jest for Laughs comedy
festival Montreal the jest respite
Festival and you know I'm one year old
as friends and my situation was
completely different like we talked
about earlier it did this is my third
Montreal festival but it had been 11
years since I had done it and man I was
[__] just tickled to be back there and
I remember you did it a few years ago
and they worked you like a donkey
and they didn't pay you very much money
and then you told me they gave you an
offer that was laughable and I just like
in talking about times you upset people
and this particular instance where it
seems like goddamn why would you burn a
bridge like that when when it seemed
like these people really respect you I
want you to talk about it that's not
what that is a bridge to nowhere that's
the whole facade of the Montreal Just
for Laughs comedy festival they pretend
to be a bridge but they're not there's
no bridge there there's no one going
anyway
since 1997 or eight when chicken get a
big deal there's no deals coming out of
there and what happened to chicken
chicken killed himself this year and I
don't
because he was a douche he was an awful
awful person when I met him he probably
has some good human qualities that I
didn't know if how did he kill himself
he hung himself I used to work at Six
Flags Over Georgia I was a bungee jump
platform manager for three days they
fired me because they didn't have a
sense of humor I tied up the guy's legs
just as he leaned forward to jump I held
up a piece of frayed rope and with no
let go you big [__] I'm joking
let go you also you know as a friends
you set a good example and that you
bought a fantastic house your make these
great improvements on it you've got like
the coolest little bungalow outlaw
hideaway and like I think you've been
really smart where a lot of comedians
have not been you know you have
something to show for your many years of
hard work and I love the cartoonish way
that you've decorated your house what
makes you happy in life Tom I'm glad you
asked that question I have no joy in
life and I think the longer you live as
a drunk the more you live you're driven
more by just gut logic and instinct than
emotion or that's how it's been for me
and when you eliminate emotion from the
equation then you just you go
everything's kind of [__] and none of
it makes sense
none of the human condition makes sense
and it's almost like tripping where Joe
Rogan is a guy who trips he sees the big
picture and he goes oh I'm happy I see
the big picture I trip and see the big
picture that this is all a joke and I go
yes it's all a joke but the joke isn't
funny
I think the joke is [__] twisted and
awkward and most things about humanity
are sad so I don't get much joy I get
joy though oh my my favorite dream is to
quit comedy as though it were a
dishwashing job on a 17 and just go yeah
[__] it I quit I can't think of nothing
that would bring me so much joy but I'm
in a place where I make
a decent living out of it just by and I
still can't find a way to go let's have
fun with this I feel like I've said
everything I could say and to go back to
jokes would be a a step back okay and
rate jokes but after you've gone through
like 9/11 like something so [__]
meaty I wanna [__] tear into this
subject and and then you everything
abortion and [__] rape and child
molestation and child pornography and
all these like well where do you draw
your boundaries at boring and I think
any step back now I can't think of any
hot-button topic that I could talk about
that annoys me that I haven't raped a
million times in different words so
Brian Hannigan my manager tells a story
about a guy that read philosophy he read
all of them he goes okay I've I've
figured it out now I'm gonna move on
yeah all right that's how I feel about
comedy I figured it out it's nothing
else I can do here except do it for a
living
and feel like a fraud I don't know that
I have any new ideas I spent the bulk of
my intellect my mediocre intellect
everything the smartest things I've had
to say I've said and now I try to
reinvent ways to save them but people
will still show up and I'll bilk them
out of money to save the same things and
I but I think I've hit my wall I have no
joy Tom what is the best Tom Road story
that you could possibly tell me
is clutching to the earth on mushrooms
we're perfectly high and Tom Rhodes said
we should do a little more but we're
perfectly high and to be a suitable host
we ground up another batch of mushrooms
with some smoothies and drank them and
within minutes we were clutching to the
driveway clutching to the pavement
trying to hold on to the earth because
we thought the earth would spin us off
and I pissed my pants purposely because
I couldn't get up and stand I try to get
up to piss and that fell right back down
like I'm just gonna piss my pants and
bingo is there to be our earth mother
[__] Saviour and she watched us and
she changed me like a baby when I pissed
my pants and when finally Tom rose
erupted a load of vomit that's the flat
the driveway gave me enough wherewithal
to wake up enough that I knew I could
stand and I get up and they looked at me
from all fours with bile dripping from
his mouth he said to me aren't you glad
we did more
that's what I remember the most is we
were we had done the second dose at my
recommendation which was a tactical
error and you piss your pants and it was
the most loving thing I've ever seen
any girlfriend or wife do for me bingo
changed your pants and your underwear
like it like changing a baby's diapers
and then I vomited my skulls out and you
were like come on Tom you're in your own
vomit and the stores were in there's the
stars in Arizona especially fizzy it's
it seems like you could jump up and grab
them they're so close and and I'm all
they're on mushrooms and I
I'm lying in my own vomit you're like
you got to get anyone a mom and I'm like
it's placenta man I just gave birth to
the universe and then Ricky Lee Jones is
saying
along together
duck I'm really happy you're one of my
oldest friends in life and even now
after all these years I still don't
understand why you gave all the same
answers on and busy lately we we belong
together
we belong together
you